are there interesting differences to you
between terms like liberal Democrat
left-wing leftist Progressive Socialist
Communist Marxist far left Center left
all these labels is there interesting
distinctions between them yeah there's
two sets of distinctions one is if you
just want to say let's define each of
these as political terms they're all
different terms you can be a progressive
ideologically but not be a member of the
democratic party many say the Democratic
party isn't even really very Progressive
so these are certainly terms that we
could Define uh in order to have a
conversation about the next thing kind
of as a precursor to a conversation
sometimes the terms are used in order to
tag someone with a certain ideology
that's not really linked to policy or
any particular political question but
they can be used positively or
negatively to just kind of say here is
the image of this individual that I have
in my mind so like Marxist is right now
very popularly being used by some on the
right
um to attack Democrats there's very few
actual marxists certainly not in
positions of power in the United States
but even among the general population
so I think it's important to distinguish
are we defining these terms because we
want to compare and contrast the ideas
that a particular group might bring to
the discussion or are we using them as
insults or to stifle conversation there
are terms that can be used to start a
conversation or to stop it and the use
of those terms is evolving rapidly month
by month so the term leftist I think is
a relatively popular term now to use the
negative context to describe
what an outraged left-wing commentator I
think what you're kind of grasping onto
is that there's probably some set of
ideas that would apply to most of those
who consider themselves to be on the
left the discussion of how that term is
mostly being used is not about policy
ideas you're accurately kind of uh
identifying that and it does seem like
Progressive is no longer being used as a
smear and leftist is being used as a
smear more at this point okay but
sometimes some of these terms are useful
like can we try to
pick the terms that are useful like
liberal and Progressive and Democrat
liberal and Progressive is there an
interesting definable distinction
between liberal and Progressive to you
that's a maybe one of the most
interesting ones 10 years ago liberal
often meant what now we mean by
Progressive
more recently the progressive
socialist-leaning part of the political
Spectrum has started to use liberal to
Mean Joe Biden to mean someone who is
not really left enough so liberal is
very interesting because I remember
talking with my audience years ago maybe
eight years ago or something like that
where I identified I'm going to now use
the term Progressive more commonly to
describe my own beliefs because liberal
has now been made a smear it's being
shifted into something else and it also
means more of like a center-left
politics so it's changed in some sense
by by necessity by force and also
because the the Spectrum has shifted to
some degree so the term liberal has
evolved
now liberal meaning some kind of uh
embodiment of the mainstream Democratic
party almost to some degree sometimes
I'm called I'm written off by you know
within my space there are all sorts of
Shades of Gray which I'm sure we can
talk about about where I am versus
should be could be or I'm wrongly placed
and sometimes an attack on me is he's
just a lib meaning I'm not left enough
I'm not Progressive socialist wherever
else you want to go so yeah the the
problem with a lot of these terms and
they're used very casually by people who
call into my show is that unless we
actually Define them each time they very
often mean very different things to
different people and often come with an
agenda attached to them and so I find
that they often stifle meaningful
conversation rather than encourage it do
you sense that there's a drifting
of uh what is the threshold to be a
progressive or is is there it should be
used Progressive synonymously with the
Democratic socialists
I think we should not use it
synonymously with Democratic Socialist
and this is where there's another
linguistic confusion and a political
confusion so we'll first talk about the
linguistic one
social democracy versus Democratic
socialism very similar words in a
different order okay
my the way I operate is democratic
socialism is actually a form of
Socialism where one would seek to
socialize ownership of the means of
production as an example social
democracy is a very uh highly regulated
form of capitalism the likes of which we
would see in northern Europe Denmark Etc
these are very different things I
associate progressivism in 2023 with
social democracy and would consider
Democratic socialism a form of actual
socialism that is different it is we're
no longer talking about a capitalist
organization of society so transition
from one to the other is a fundamental
shift in house in how Society operates
then absolutely and when you talk about
social democracy you're talking about
socializing a couple more things than we
socialize in most modern uh capitalist
countries I had this conversation with
Patrick Bett David recently social
democracy is okay we've socialized the
military already in the United States
we've socialized some health care in the
sense of like the VA and Medicaid Etc
we're talking about socializing a couple
more things still in a capitalist
country Democratic socialism would be
something beyond that and and as someone
who is not a Democratic Socialist myself
I'm I'm maybe not the best
advocate for explaining exactly how that
system would function but it would have
some version of socializing ownership of
the means of production businesses Etc